ce qui est intéressant de voir c'est que
sur les 20 vous en avez 16 qui ont deux
ou trois classes donc là on touche bien
aux difficultés spécifiques de la
ruralité avec un petit souvent une
question de personnel qui n'est pas
selon le maire compétent pour le respect
strict du protocole sanitaire et donc
une seule commune d'importance donc map
la vive qui elle n'a pas souhaité
heureux ouvre ses écoles donc c'est
surtout en milieu rural ce qui m'amène à
dire une réflexion est engagée avec le
préfet avec le conseil départemental
avec les associations des maires avec
lesquels j'étais ce matin pour voir si
on ne pouvait pas venir en aide
en appui à ces communes à ses 19
communes donc voilà c'est la
photographie du moment mais c'est une
photographie qui pourra évoluer